All right good old-fashioned portal fun yeah it's
gonna be classic episode 40 view commentary crude
characters here we go Rick and Morty time! Welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this is my full Rick
and Morty season six episode six video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel I'm doing videos for all the episodes be
sure to subscribe to get them also explain what's
happening with the brief break that is going on
it'll come back for the rest of the episodes
in a couple weeks careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll just
start at the beginning and go through shot by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we
go along starting with the episode title it was
called Juricksic Mort a reference to the original
Jurassic Park movie this is the second episode to
directly parody Jurassic Park the original one
was during Anatomy Park in season one this time
it's a little bit more of a literal reference
because of the actual dinosaurs in the episode
but the actual plot of the episode is meant to
be a combination of Jurassic Park with a parody
of the arrival movie in the aliens coming to Earth
during which the aliens offer these great things
with no apparent ill intent behind it like they're
not trying to do something sinister or take over
the planet so in the episode this pushes Rick's
buttons because as he says he doesn't believe
that the dinosaurs are truly being selfless like
there's no difference between being selfish and
being selfless and they're really just trying to
High Road everyone and prove how they're Superior
to everyone else they made a joke about this on
South Park it's like getting high by sniffing
your own farts basically Rick successfully proves
during the episode that everybody acts a little
bit selfish in some way when the New Finally
relent and kill their enemy they also further
prove his point when they close his Rift which he
specifically asked them not to do like that was
their Petty way of getting back at him forgetting
at them in the first place in previous Seasons
they always have jokes about how they're going to
do sequels to the interdimensional cable episode
but then never actually do it this entire episode
was full of references like that like things in
people characters Big Ideas that they set up
but never actually pay off actually paying off
a couple of things during the episode especially
the portal guns I believe his brand of beer has
been featured before on the series in the portal
that he throws it in is just a joke to him being
so lazy that he doesn't want to get off the couch
so he just portals it to another place on the
planet because at this early point of the episode
he hasn't totally fixed interdimensional no travel
yet they set up the joke with the rift in space
just sitting there not doing anything like I said
it's one of the many moments in the episode where
they choke on plot points that they haven't paid
off yet like big things that they set up and
then never actually do anything with they wind
up paying that moment off with a big fourth wall
break where he starts talking about the actual
television show like we could have milked that
for an entire season or at least a three episode
Arc but Rick has known that he's a fictional
character inside a television show since season
one like even in last week's episode he made
another reference to being a fictional character
inside a television show they said it the whole
bit with the portal gun being almost finished when
he brings through the Cthulhu monster from all the
opening credit scenes in every single episode on
accident I love that he sprays it with water like
a cat and that's enough to get it to go away like
it's a big cat basically there have been so many
theories across the many many seasons about when
they'd finally do a Cthulhu episode and like I
said this whole episode just making jokes about
them not paying off big plot points that says set
up is meant to pay the Cthulhu plot point off from
the beginning of the series when they they're
in the car and he admits to Morty that he's
purposefully slowing his work on the portal gun
and fixing things like fixing the rift is because
Morty won't stop asking him about it is also the
writers of the show directly addressing the fans
kind of making a joke about the fans bothering
them about writing episodes and Seasons that are
more like the original Seasons like the original
Dynamic of the show so it's like Rick is speaking
as if he were Dan and Justin speaking directly to
the fans saying the more you bother us about the
show the more we'll prolong making it like it used
to be that's also a part of his rant at the end of
the episode too like ah we're gonna be doing way
more Canon stuff way more core characters way more
fun portal Adventures where we go and wreck stuff
when Morty goes to his classroom Mr goldenfold
and the rest of the class also acknowledge all the
crazy stuff that's happened during the run of the
series in between episodes when they freak out of
the side of him like it's meant to be a bunch of
Adventures that we haven't seen during the actual
episodes previously we've seen other people at the
school reference the events of previous episodes
but I think their reference to the previous
Adventures this time is way more overt than it's
ever been before like is them acknowledging that
every episode is about something crazy happening
to the planet zoom in hands on the chalkboard
there's a ton of jokes all over the chalkboard
and this is true of pretty much all the episodes
that take place in his classroom it says Morty and
Corey already have detention there's a couple of
dongs all over the chalkboard up here on the
left it says babies come from space which is
another reference to Morty and Summers baby Naruto
which they also referenced earlier this season and
they reference again at the end of the episode
as well like they keep referencing the space
baby they've already referenced it several times
this season that's another one of those major plot
points they haven't completely wrapped up yet Mr
goldenfold references a bunch of other Adventures
that we didn't see during the actual episodes like
that happened between the episodes the latest one
being him being forced to lick all the toilets
which he's super self-conscious about apparently
then when the dinosaur spaceships arrive the
actual physical spaceships are a reference to
the spaceships from the arrival movie there are a
couple of special guest stars in the episode Lisa
Kudrow everybody probably recognized and if you
didn't recognize him Jason Mraz the musician also
plays one one of the dinosaurs obviously Keith
David comes back as the U.S president as well on
the news the Chiron also makes a reference about
the events of previous episodes with previous
alien attacks like do these ones come in peace for
once as opposed to all the other times you could
also call that a big get schwifty reference too
because it's another president episode they have
a real weird Pizza Mamma Mia Italian reference
with these characters across a couple different
scenes and then the new Canon backstory for the
Rick and Morty Multiverse like this is actually
Canon to the history of their world along with the
rest of the Multiverse as well is that dinosaurs
evolved on Earth became a space-faring race
most of them left the planet trying to help
other planets Thrive they developed their own
portal Tech many many eons before Rick did it's
way more advanced than Rick's portals and then
they decided it would be more noble to help their
own Universe before going to help other people's
universes they make a whole mask virus joke about
that too like it's better to put your own mask
on before yelling at other people about putting
their masks on it was a very politically charged
episode they also explained that what happened is
as these dinosaurs were evolving this other life
form was de-evolving and this is where you get to
like another big political metaphor because the
dinosaurs were meant to be like this alt left
crowd they get super liberal and the meteorite
race the D evolved and is like their arch enemy is
meant to be the alt-right so it's the whole idea
that the alt-right is always coming for the alt
left and it's like a mutually assured destruction
scenario and when Rick is commenting on that
later in the episode he's making jokes about the
culture War like how this is bad for everybody
like no actual problems are getting solved like
it's just a bunch of people yelling at a bunch
of other people when they pull up the list of
technological advancements they also include stuff
like anime body pillows celebrity presidents is a
trump joke Amazon Prime comments sections Dogecoin
and just social media in general they make a ton
of Marvel movie references too when they say that
they've now done 29 so far and 14 were on the
way that's actually accurate up to Thor love
and thunder they've been 29 Marvel Studios movies
the 14 more that he references start with black
Panther wakanda forever which will actually
come out later this season I've already done
a big trailer video for it so I'll link it below
in the description all the way up to Avengers 6
Secret Wars the president then makes an Avengers
end game Thanos reference when he talks about the
invasion and then they make an Ant-Man 3 Quantum
Mania reference when He suggests that they finish
rounding out ant-man's character I think this
is also the first time that we learned that
the president's first name is Curtis then the
dinosaurs fix everything there's no more world
hunger like it's meant to be this perfect Planet
like no more suffering no more want for anything
the whole song that they play over this montage
is also them just repeating the names of real
dinosaurs that just sounds super weird like these
are all real dinosaurs they clown on Tyler Perry
movies they make a joke about most of the audience
for young female tick talkers being pedos which
isn't totally wrong like there's definitely a lot
of that going on in real life so watch out when
summer says she's broke that's also ironic because
creators on Tick Tock really get paid terribly to
begin with so even if she was doing really well
on Tick Tock with those Dance videos she would
not have been earning a ton of money to begin with
it rick clowns on the family for basically turning
into versions of Jerry like utterly useless people
that don't do anything which they pay off with his
book that he wrote all about his philosophy about
not failing because you never try like as long as
you don't try you can never fail which they also
pay off at the end of the episode when Jerry has
to try to write a second book and thus begins
to fail that's why he gives up and defeat all
depressed because he finally failed again like
he has trouble starting the second book so he's
trying meaning that he's failing again on his
computer if you look around he's got locations
of the pieces of the Titanic because it broke
into pieces when it sank he's got a beekeeper
video which is a call back to his beekeeping in
the episode where Summer's friend wanted to bang
him the delete this folder is probably just more
cringe stuff like you would expect from Jerry his
first forgotten stuff folder is full of pandas
falling snake wearing a mini skirt ugly dog pics
they're meant to be references to Old memes that
the world has forgotten like just old stuff that
used to be cool in his other forgotten step folder
he's got three copies of his manuscript with Joe
folks about how it's the final version like
no no this is the final one then no no this
is the final final one like he keeps writing new
versions of his manuscript about not trying but
the whole ethos is that you're not supposed to try
if you actually read the opening text to this page
here it reads like a third grader wrote it but
there's another reference to Morty and Summer's
space baby in it like he mentions that then says
that he doesn't want to talk about it then I think
they've done Molly jokes with the president in the
past but they have another one which they pay off
when he keeps what Rick gave him and then takes it
at the end of the episode and tries to come on to
him the whole bit with the ribs joint is actually
a joke about House of Cards on that show the Frank
character would go to this ribs joint all the time
and he had a similar relationship with that owner
as they do during the Rick and Morty episode they
have another Westworld joke when they reveal that
the owner is actually a robot that Rick created
like he created this whole scenario they also
make it seem like they needed this rib joint on
the regular too they make a ton of super specific
YouTube jokes and if you spend a lot of time on
YouTube you'll recognize that all this is real
stuff like the auto play joke about just watching
random videos one right after the other and the
joke about seeing the grammarly ads too many times
just because that ad shows up all over YouTube all
the time in no joke when I was making this video
and I was looking for some b-roll on my YouTube
channel to include for this part of the video
to talk about YouTube a grammarly ad queued up
automatically when I clicked on one of my videos
Rick and Morty being super meta and speaking the
truth the president makes a Zero Dark Thirty
reference that was the movie about the military
killing Bin Laden he also calls Rick autistic
which Rick implied that he was in a previous
episode and he Bargains with the president to
become the host of the next Oscars and they make a
big joke about Hollywood at the end of the episode
too about how it doesn't really matter like nobody
actually cares about the Oscars because it's all
scripted Morty makes a reference to the original
Jurassic Park movie that was the line of dialogue
from the original movie which he later complains
to Rick about for not acknowledging his reference
they make a Dr Manhattan teleportation reference
because when the dinosaurs teleport them back to
the garage the way that they teleport them looks
similar to the way that Dr Manhattan teleports
people and it also kind of blows people up at
the same time too it almost looks like the same
thing he makes a Sean Penn virtue signaling joke
about people who used to be terrible and then over
correct becoming super political later in life to
try and make up for being terrible when they were
younger I think the ironic 90s genius reference is
about a movie of the same name from the 90s with a
character like Morty who's a genius that pretends
to be a badass in order to gain more friends when
he makes the reference about the Zions those were
also small magazines that people self-publish
which is also something that happened back in
the 80s and the 90s before social media sites like
YouTube really took off he makes another Jurassic
Park Laura Dern reference to fishing in the
dinosaur poop in on all these planets that they
go to they make these jokes about them being super
dumb and not understanding history and thinking
the dinosaurs did all these weird things coming up
with these big theories about what they actually
did which they pay off at the end of the episode
saying that the theories were actually correct
like the dinosaurs did actually ride around on
skateboards which I believe is meant to be at
Denver the Last Dinosaur cartoon reference just
because he was a skateboarding dinosaur the second
planet they visit makes a more literal Jurassic
Park reference when they say they're going to
create their own Jurassic Park movies like our own
bad movies about cloning dinosaurs and theme parks
Rick references Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 which
either means that he really likes playing retro
games because that games from the early 2000s
or 20 years ago he was also playing video games
before Morty was born then I already explained
the sentient meteor species is meant to be the
show's metaphor for the alt-right just in general
to make a joke about Apple keynote speeches I'm
not sure why they stole Jerry's book maybe because
they wanted to avoid paying him money just because
they wanted to show you they were kind of dirt
bags really and they also wanted the entire planet
to give up and stop fighting them on everything
so that's why they wanted everybody to read and
believe in Jerry's ethos in keeping with their 90s
jokes Rick interrupts them with a very 90s looking
video on the big screen they have an Anderson
Cooper bit like he does actually have a show
called Anderson Cooper 360 in real life they have
a Joe Rogan podcast joke and this is actually what
his podcast set looks like they also have a joke
about all the prod products that he usually does
ads for on his show like the stuff, the stuff he's
a big smoker the whole thing with the rear naked
choke hold is just a joke about him being into
MMA they do a Wendy Williams daytime talk show
bit then they pay off the bid about the president
using Rick as a dealer who comes on to Rick and
kind of ignores him like yeah yeah it's just the
Molly talking at the Oscars they have a bunch of
parodies of real life celebrities and one of the
reasons why I think that they had the Oscars bit
was to say that a lot of these celebrities are
also kind of high on their own farts and trying
to be superior than everyone else kind of like
the dinosaurs were in the episode this huge dude
obviously meant to be the rock with the tattoos
all over him Ted Danson his wife Mary Steen virgin
Johnny Depp is behind them this is Adam Driver
Rick makes a joke about everyone in Hollywood
being communist which is a callback to the old
Hollywood Blacklist in the 1950s they do the
Tom Hanks Wilson bit from Castaway and then they
make a joke about Will Smith slapping Chris Rock
when he says everything at the Oscars is scripted
even that one thing then Rick actually calls out
the dinosaurs for thinking they're Superior to
everyone by allowing themselves to be killed by
the meteorite he makes another reference to him
fixing his portal gun but procrastinating it when
he lands on Mars in the background you can see the
NASA rover from real life like that's currently on
Mars right now as we speak he makes an Elon Musk
reference because in real life Elon Musk has this
huge goal to get humans to Mars to establish a
Mars colony and he's pumping a bunch of money and
energy into it way more than a lot of the other
rich people in the world him getting the dinosaurs
to actually kill the asteroid is just proving that
they are also just a little bit self-interested
and they get him back by closing up his Rift
which he then breaks the fourth wall referencing
the show talking about how they could have milked
it for an entire season maybe three episode Arc
back at home with Summer comments on it being way
too hot outside that's just a reference to global
warming like now that the dinosaurs have left
global warming is a problem again for them the
crypto for Bears toes joke on her social media is
a spam joke like my account in real life gets all
kinds of spam replies like this on the regular in
earlier the dinosaurs had cleaned up social media
gotten rid of the weirdos all the spam but now
that they're gone all that stuff has come back
to social media I already explained the Jerry joke
like he's a failure again now because he has to
try and now he's failing thus at making his second
book but in the ending Rick finally fixes his
portal gun they pay off the boob World joke again
Morty's already been to boob world like they've
referenced it in several episodes before in his
rant this season is all about the show going back
to its old formula like doing more Canada stuff
doing core characters more social commentary we're
going to be wrecking stuff all over the Multiverse
so we'll see how they pay that off in episode 7 or
if they don't pay it off like maybe that's the
joke in the actual post-credits scene they pay
off the joke about the dinosaurs actually riding
skateboards and partying the way that the aliens
believe they did like all of their theories about
what they actually got up to were totally true and
the big reminder is that the show is on break till
November 30th and then they'll just air the rest
of the four episodes to the beginning of December
repeat after me Morty next time on Rick and Morty
next time on Rick and Morty so like I said the
big question is is how they're going to pay off
this rant from the end of episode 6 like will the
show actually do what they said they were going to
do or is it a call back to the entire episode
where they joke about them not paying off big
plot points that they set up if you spotted any
other Easter eggs or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
them Below in the comments in my next video we'll
post as soon as episode 7 releases in a couple
weeks while you wait for everything everyone
click here for my house of the Dragon episode 9
video and click here for my new episode 8 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one please!